ne me suis jamais drogué de toute ma vie
je voudrais jamais plusieurs candidats
qui nous l'ont expliqué effectivement
c'est que il demandait souvent aux
vigiles d'aller leur chercher de la
drogue ou même à des gens de la boîte de
prod mais c'est quelque chose en moi je
demande un truc à mokhtar c'est d'aller
chercher des makrouts 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
tsahal est étonné de me voir c'est
normal on se connaît pas qui colombie
c'est peut-être on s'est trompé il ya
erreur c'est pas c'est pas le bon
alors là donc elle attendait que j'y
arrive pas ce que c'est je rappelle le
principe de l'émission 7 mois de
relation virtuelle et ensuite il se rend
compte qu'elle a tant dit parce que ça
17 mois qu'ils parlaient ensemble
c'était vraiment important pour vous
était amoureuse de lui ben oui et
j'aimerais te présenter mes excuses de
ne pas
avoir honoré le rendez vous j'espère que
tu comprendre je t'embrasse
[Musique]
en fait
administrativement parlant
et qu'il est marié avec une femme 1 puis
4 coup
une braguette là on fait des trucs ça
fait plus d'un an un peu plus d'un an
qu'ils sont plus ensemble ils sont
séparés chacun vit chez lui chacun avoue
fait sa vie l'un comme l'autre ça oui on
est où là ils se déplacent même pas pour
me le dire lui-même il envoie 100 m on
est sans cesse voir tu envoies ton ami
avec une lettre mal écrite veut et
m'expliquant que tu es marié depuis
quatre ans qu'est-ce que je l'avais dit
au sujet du mensonge si la phrase est
long tu me le dis je vais la raccourcir
tomber le mensonge on en a parlé répond
sinon ça va je te plaît physiquement
c'est bon
s'appelait marc regarde-moi partir
qu'est ce que vous dites aux gens qui
disent que vous êtes une comédienne et
que tout ça c'est du fake mais s'ils
disent que je suis une comédienne
j'accepte si pour eux après on peut me
repérer 1,6 à jean dujardin domaine qui
donne tout ça
[Rires]
je sais pas il n'y a pas de souci
maintenant moi je vais dans une émission
telle que celle ci je sais très bien qu
elle va passer devant la france entière
le monde et donc moi je dois aller me
ridiculiser voilà donc vous si vous
étiez vraiment vous aviez des sentiments
pour guy georges est aujourd'hui avec
dit
on en est là
où çà et là on est là ou là là bas je ne
suis pas du
tout fait ensemble ou pas ensemble c'est
un bien grand - c'est pour ça que je
préfère dire qu'on est là vous êtes mon
essai de thomas c oui oui il nous reste
et vous le croyez locaux keskia didier
le reste ça veut dire quoi le reste
alors elle vous plait pas avoir peur des
mots moi je la prends un malin coucher
non non non c'était prévu si tout
s'était bien passé on était censé passer
le week-end dans ça il m'a dit qu'hoarau
on va aller faire un week-end après
cette vue macha match auquel j'étais
contente mais voyez comme je vous dis
qu'il va divorcer que c'est finalement
marié je suis pas connu mais il s est ce
qu'on a mais par rapport à la question
il laisse ce qu'on appelle le bénéfice
du butin si on peut considérer que vous
êtes en couple aujourd'hui même si on
n'avait pas fait un truc un sacré quoi
lannoy mais faut-il fais comme tu dis là
il parle pas
[Applaudissements]
je vous avais kent
non non donc vous êtes ton et la capa de
fin des trucs ouais c'est toi
donc c'est un homme bon voilà quoi on
est là quoi
plusieurs scènes qui n'ont pas été
coupées au montage montrerait certains
candidats en train de consommer de la
drogue et plus précisément de la cocaïne
et ce n'est pas la première fois que les
fans du programme à l'herbe sur un tel
problème la saison dernière déjà une
autre séquence avait été relevé par les
internautes tendent à la grecque pris en
flag en train de sniffer de la cocaïne
en plein tournage des marseillais
épisode 49 si la production n'a pas
réagi la candidate maeva gainey m'a tenu
à faire taire les rumeurs je démens
complètement ces rumeurs c'est
totalement interdit de prendre de la
drogue sur les tournages de productions
nous l'interdît formellement j'en ai
jamais vu surtout les tournages que
j'étais alors images choc diffusé dans
les marseillais y at il de la drogue
dans la télé réalité
une vidéo qui hacker qui circule sur les
réseaux sociaux où on voit effectivement
maeva avait quelque chose au niveau du
nez y en avait eu une jambe et
une avec greg également effectivement
tout le monde se pose la question de
savoir si si la drogue dans la télé
réalité et je sais que magali voilà on
se connaît bien elle va dire que non
mais malheureusement oui c'est cesser
ses limites même plus à se créer un
secret de dire qu'il ya de la drogue
dans la télé réalité il ya même des
candidats qui ont été condamnées pour
trafic de stupéfiants dylan alors il
très gentil et tout ça mais il ne
correspond pas j'ai déjà amoureuse dans
ma vie et je sais ce que c'est le
sentiment de tomber amoureuse mais là
que je ressens pour dylan
malheureusement c'est toujours rien
voilà alors maeva et je sais que maeva
priori ça c'est une grosse connerie
complet voilà alors dites nous pourquoi
mais c'est une grosse connerie parce
qu'elle a montré sur ça heureusement est
vraiment elle a une bande eu avec elle
comme quoi on peut arriver à dire
beaucoup de conneries
la montre et sa vertu des voilà elle
regardait son truc regardez alors on la
mettez la vidéo je ne me suis jamais
drogué de toute ma vie je veux de
regrets jamais je suis en qui drogue
voilà est-ce que vous avez vu dans les
marseillais c'est cette palette que au
sial m'a donné une autre bien la palette
vous voyez en fait le dos rond voyez ça
c'est le plastique est en fait celle du
doré par dessus et en fait ça sans
enlever sa ministre mais greg il a été à
plusieurs reprises surpris avec de la
cocaïne apparemment regarder
j'amène ma vie je me remettrai jamais de
ma vie je me remettrai jamais de ma vie
je me remettrai connaître nous avions
fait une enquête une une journaliste de
public annabelle jeantaise effet une
enquête l'année dernière et elle avait
eu notamment émis les amarres qui a nous
avait expliqué sur le tournage des
marseillais en australie qu'elle avait
pris pour la première fois un rail de
coke avec une une influence ce zune ça
faisait un bout de cette année ça
viendra lorsque ce qui nous expliquait
on a eu plusieurs candidats qui nous
l'ont expliqué effectivement c'est que
il demandait souvent aux vigiles d'aller
leur chercher de la drogue ou même à des
gens de la boîte de prod mais c'est
quelque chose en moi je demande un truc
à mokhtar semaine chercher des macros
d'un ben c'est tout sur les tournages
effectivement il ya de la drogue qui est
fourni aux candidats il ya même de la
drogue c'est très grave non mais tu veux
pas dire mais j'ai affirmé mais mais
mais même si voilà je risque un procès
en diffamation
mais il ya même certains candidats je me
souviens de jeremstar qui a expliqué
qu'une fois il avait il avait parlé avec
une candidate qui avait manqué de faire
une overdose parce qu'elle avait planqué
de la drogue dans son temps pacs pour
pouvoir la mener sur le tournage donc
donc voilà c'est que c'est pas ces voix
là c'est ce sont les jeunes qui alors on
part bernard castagnet pour qui en avait
fait sa mère est sûre sur six est story
la vérité c'est que on savait que sa
rentrée on cherchait jamais comment sa
rentrée et ce avec une saison qui était
un peu compliqué pour nous il ya des
caméras partout vous n'êtes pas des
réformes mais maintenant oui je la
vérité c'est que y'avait asie amea
système de livraison qui passait par les
cols de chemise et la blanchisserie
c'est le cas de dire oui effectivement
il envoyé dans l'ain chan et quand il
revenait bien propre dans l'école il y
avait effectivement la cocaïne et on l'a
trouvée comme ça c'est alors par contre
là où je vous rejoint pas je crois pas
du tout que la prod non un complice sur
c'était pas du couscous c'est pas moi la
fin des candidats les pauvres candidats
et les pauvres participants c'est des
rats de laboratoire en fait et moi j'en
veux énormément à la prendre parce qu'au
quai sont pas complices mais malgré tout
ils sont complices parce que c'est ce
qu'ils recherchent ils recherchent le
buzz et recherchera non ils cherchent
mais que des gens sortent de leurs gonds
qui se parlent mal que ça coco c'est pas
mal
quand on est sans substance gérer les
débats onze pages vues alors je ne vois
pas aucune faute de france alors
qu'aucune porte de france doit d'être
complice de ça que la prod oriente les
nutons oui ou non mais c'est vrai que ça
marche plus et non mais alors ils vont
laisser pas ce que va faire non pas sa
renault mais c'est pas nouveau ça fait
les images par dont vous parlez d'une
image mais vous rendez compte de ce que
vous dites vous reprenez une image qui
est fausse et maryvonne faut sauver
par les ouvrages de grève qu'elle est
fausse comment savez vous comment sur
les choses et vous croyez qu'ils sont
couchés gratter d'étiquette sur la
[Applaudissements]
shogun il a été bien fait
je suis maman
c'est parce qu'ils ont été isolés ils
ont eu deux camps même de la prison avec
suris motivante onglet mais moi j'aime
ou pas demain que ils étaient treize ans
messieurs plein juste greg grecs on est
alors d'accord grec c'est fou by van on
est sûr que c'est faux grecs aux idéaux
mais un candidat qui a été dopé en un an
mais si vous devez arrêter tout le monde
le sait on a justifié de gestion sur le
chemin est ce que vous pouvez nous
assurer aujourd'hui cas pas de drogue
dans les marseillais ou dans une autre
télé ralité pas d'étude et aujourd'hui
voilà drogue l'humeur même moi je peux
vous assurer c'est qu'à pas de vendre de
la drogue ce qui est en passe et je vous
dis y'a pas de grand-case ils sont cons
actuellement
les oscars très joyeux très heureux très
coloré où tu es bien tout est nickel il
n'y a aucun aucun scandale jusqu'à une
blague de chris rock sur la femme de
will smith qui est pas passé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ils ont quant à elles continuent la
cérémonie en mode normal et will smith
un des meilleurs acteurs j'espère que
l'académie l'un des trois nouveaux ce
qui est incroyable très secrète rock
comme à son habitude a fait une vanne
sûr que ça nourrit donc il y là il a
animé la cérémonie en faisant une vanne
sur jada pinkett en se moquant en fait
du fait qu'elle soit qu'elles aient la
tête rasée ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que j'adore souffre d'une maladie qui
s'appelle halo péquiste à dire qu'elle
perd ses cheveux et will smith la
extrêmement mal pris et il s'est hissé
levée de seine et la gifle est devant
tout le monde ce n'était pas tout le
monde a cru que c'était un gag mais pas
du tout c'est pas du tout inquiet fox
part d'audience du genre tu lis je suis
sûr que c'est pas un gag en fait ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en seul ou à
deux miss et christophe qui a déjà un
contentieux qui doit depuis de
nombreuses parce qu en fait lors de la
88e cérémonie des oscars will smith
avait boycotté
la cérémonie en disant je ne suis pas
nommé c'est du racisme et caetera et du
coup christophe déjà à la crise troc à
la lors de cette jolie lors de cette
cérémonie avait charrié avait charrié sa
femme il l'avait extrêmement mal pris je
bougeais jada elle n'a pas rigolé à la
cccc chat dakic a fait signe à son à son
mari et donc il s'est levé pour défendre
l'honneur de sa de sa femme est toujours
dangereux ou la will smith il a voulu
faire une démonstration testostérone
parce que tout le monde sait que jada le
trail le trompe à tire larigot ils ont
fait vibrer tout pas que ça se constitue
avec ton pote il ya eu avec tupac mais
il ya eu aussi il ya eu aussi avec un
autre rappeur de 21 ans - quels qu'ils
ont hébergé et avec qui elle l'a trompée
et aussi eu avec marc anthony le père
des enfants de jennifer lopez donc en
fait est connu dans tout le hollywood
que chadal le trompe sans vergogne et si
vous voulez ça d'ailleurs même les nerfs
à fleur de peau où tu sois là et là il a
voulu montrer que c'était lui l'homme de
la maison et que même si elle le trompe
il avait déplu cognette et cgt juste une
démonstration de force excessive oui
bien sûr
i will smith paraissait plutôt
embarrassées au moment de recevoir son
oscar quelques minutes plus tard
j'espère que l'académie il invitera à
nouveau il a tenu à présenter ses
excuses à chris rock sur son compte
instagram comportement la nuit dernière
aux oscars était inacceptable et
inexcusable je voudrais publiquement te
demander pardon en crise ce que j'ai
fait était déplacée et j'ai eu tort
entre les deux hommes la hache de guerre
semble déjà enterré mais l'académie a
tout de même ouvert une enquête si vous
suisse devrait bel et bien conserver son
oscar il pourrait s'exposer à des
sanctions disciplinaires
il mélange absolument tout moi je m'en
fous de son passé et à elle et à lui ce
que je vois c'est un mec qui colle
littéralement un pain
pourquoi parce qu'il a gagné en tant
qu'acteur d'emploi faut pas tout
mélanger la raison revanche qui se soit
excusé ça me semble la moindre des
choses est que les sanctions
disciplinaires ça me semble aussi la
moindre des choses mais j'accepte et je
pense qu'il faut accepter totalement les
excuses claires sincères et bien sûr
will smith a pas rêvé le petn un peu
c'est le couple elle est très très mal
et on voit bien que voter une telle
violence c'est que c'était
malheureusement le couple est pas très
bien c'est la goutte d'eau un couple qui
va bien ça s'énerve pas comme ça donc
mais se faire par là c'est que j'accepte
totalement ses excuses très bien
acceptée en revanche en revanche oui
bien sûr il faut lui retirer son oscar
savoir ce que ces
vielles que devant des milliards de
dollars adaptateur et demandé qu'en est
il mathieu c'est quelqu'un mathieu
mathieu salariale voir
ce qu'a reconnu le talon non non non non
non non non academy l'académie des
oscars des césar je n'ai pas tapé c'est
le talent dans mes habitudes de pensée
j'avais bien sûr excuses acceptées il
pourra revenir gagner un prochain mais
celui là pour lui retirer j'aurais fait
pareil fait une mauvaise blague son mari
est malade et voilà et on me dit voilà
c'est pas elle a les cheveux rasés parce
qu'elle a un cancer ont fait cette
blague là moi je me lève et je lui casse
la tête absolument
[Applaudissements]
et
alors le passé ça m'est déjà arrivé
d'aller chercher quelqu'un qui avait
même à parler de ma femme sert à rien
oui bah oui ça olivier guillon ah oui
série serrée qui me rappelle sur le
plateau jean battault de chassieu j'ai
senti sa femme à nos services étaient
chier dessus elle était nommée au sens
propre il espère revenir dessus vraiment
de répit n'était pas vraiment il a fait
vraiment un très fort mois est vraiment
live et après vous l'avez dit quoi
raconter une robe honorable puisque il
m'avait il y avait vraiment chier ça
remet sur ma famille et c'est un fait et
les vies d'innombrables chiffres ci
dessus qui est critères d'acceptabilité
alors alors là j ça passe le pitbull est
ce que ce serait dans le volet vous
n'êtes pas d'accord et je trouve que ça
s'appelle en fait c'est sûr de cette
gifle les excuses heureusement qui les a
fait elles sont très bien sont claires
nettes et précises moi je laisserais
sont en hausse car malgré tout bah oui
mais voilà mais c'est juste le degré
zéro je trouve deux voies l'adresse de
la civilisation c'est la violence n'a
été jugé un disque dit géraldine et
mathieu absolument indigne heureusement
que chris rock à un esprit beaucoup plus
magnanime que vous il n'a pas porté
plainte il ya des émissions de ça il a
été pendant des heures il ainsi il ya
des émissions de télé pendant des heures
qu'il incite à porter plainte comme ils
portent pas plainte et qui a pas eu
d'armé temps mais will smith ni de
blessures la police n'ouvre pas une eau
bien eybens et séoul où les gens lui
disent porter plainte mais je comprends
tout à fait j'aurais fait exactement
pareil
bon sang vous avez poussé un coup de
gueule sur vos réseaux après avoir vu
une émission de lundi on à l'extrait qui
vous a fait réagir c'était face à myriam
balle au mbba regarde
il a été
jusqu'à ma mort
c'est pas facile qu'ils ont été ils ont
aidé au mieux quand même de la prison
avec sme en imaginant progrès mais moi j
nos peines mais qu il était trader
messieurs bien alors vincent
qu'est ce qui vous a alors qu'est-ce qui
se passe alors qu'isis pas alors mois
déjà ça fait trois ans que c'est terminé
moi j'ai payé mon dû j'ai fait de la
prison pour ça j'ai fait 28 jours mais
pourquoi on me ressort toujours prêt à
vous avez fait de la prison vincent lors
c'était pour la drogue d'accord
avant de parler c'était pas dans un
tournage c'était à l'extérieur à
amsterdam ce qu'est vraiment rien à voir
aux sommations oui d'accord voilà la
corée qui avait pris 28 jours de prison
oui parce que en fait tout le monde a
cru que c'était moins le trafiquant d'un
golf c'est pour ça qu'ils ont regardé en
gros ben voilà alors juste vincent
après et doit aujourd'hui terminée tout
ça oui il m'a regardé je suis welt
maintenant enfin ballade rock
alors
je t'explique moi tu veux ça fait trois
ans qu'on parle de sa façon le shogun
voilà mais ça c'était le passé
maintenant c'est le présent non mesdames
de la maison sont 115 justement j'ai
pris cet exemple de vincent qui
effectivement reconnaît aujourd'hui
qu'il a quand même pris de la drogue je
vois même pas pourquoi tu as fait vous
avez pas excuse moi je te tutoie alors
on sait cette vidéo franchement tu me
tues malus moins d'armes avant de faire
du buzz sur toi mais finalement c'est
toi qui fait le buzz non parce que les
enjeux tenait juste des exemples était
très factuelle en fait l'exemple c'est
un
exemple en droit dia ba oui en fait
l'exemple c'est que ça fait trois ans
que j'ai jamais rien dit donc là je dis
merci cyril de la main mais c'est
important parce que moi je fais 3 jean
louis merrien six et abandonner alors
qualité voilà et je voudrais dire que tu
as été relaxé j'aimais bien mais après
ça on flamands impliqués dans la pièce
donc je parle pas flamand a annoncé
leurs noms annoncés on sait je te lis je
dis merci par la justice belge confirmé
info les les candidats pendant les jours
off vont se ravitailler dans les
différents pays en plus souvent des pays
où il ya facilement accès à des produits
à des stupéfiants donc oui je confirme
mes infos et je veux dire c'est pas
secret de polichinelle on sait par
exemple de une personne comme comme
loana qui a avoué s'être drogué qui se
droguait pendant pendant pendant les
journées à fond on a des candidats je
vais pas citer non mais il ya des
candidats qui ont fait pipi dans leur
lit parce qu'elle était tellement
cocaïne et que voilà elle se rendait
même pas compter qu'on fini aux urgences
c'est des choses voilà qui se sont
passées alors peut-être que toi tu n'as
pas été tu n'y a pas eu la complicité de
la production est ce que là que la
production le séquel la drogue mais bien
sûr il ya des caméras partout comme en
valais c'est ça
oui mais voilà maintenant je me cachais
réellement je me cachais pour faire ça
donc peut-être qu'ils savent d'après ma
faut bien caché sa wii est le sable est
pire encore ça les arrange presque bien
avoir des précisions vous avez eu dix
jeux les personnes ont fait pire que moi
elles font encore de la télé ça
clairement c'est de la télé réalité
donc ça sous-entend à mon avis quand
même que la consommation de drogue est
répandu dans les télé réalités la sarre
est ce qu'un aveu de votre part parce
que en gros bas en fait pire commode
dans le sens que moi j'ai assumé
vraiment bah moi ce que je faisais que
y'en a qui l'ont caché et n'a pas été
vue moi j'ai assumé des départs oui
c'est moi et voilà basta chao dans
quelle émission par exemple dans les
hanches mais les gros la peinture alors
que tu parles avant moi bonjour comment
ça va
je voudrais pas me mettre à bas donc je
disais que en gros ses gardes
déjà tu ne t'en fais pas là
et pas du tout parce que ça en fait
c'est tout le temps on me reproche
vincent non c'est ça c'est lourd à force
de dire voilà c'est lourd donc on disait
oui dans quelle émission donc je crois
que ma dernière que j'ai fait c'était la
villa et vu j'étais pas vraiment bien
bien je crois que j'en avais trouvés ou
plus mais dans la wilaya j'en avais cru
mais il est qu'il est valide et non mais
mais pas trouvé
la solution à mes yeux quand j'en serais
sa déclaration révèle un
côté rebelle où ça ne venait pas avoir
trouvé c'est dans le sens où il était
dépendant d'accord voilà et qui est
abandonnée quand on a besoin de sa dose
et quand ils ne dépendent pas quelque
chose on fait tout pour trouver toqué
d'autres candidats qui tendance non moi
même y aller il a les mains libres même
et c'était le jour off un accord voilà
simplement comme on va très bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]